So now, move down all of this.
Let's ask the question,
what can we do about trying to now
be able to recover
transformations from images?
So basically what that means for
recovering is given f of x,
y, can I generate g of x, y?
But also, can I also kind of
learn the transformation itself?
So what it basically means is given an
image f and given the transformed image,
if I know the axis for both of them,
this would be x and y, and
of course this would be x prime,
y prime.
If we know what f and g are, can we
recover the transformation, t itself?
To achieve this,
one question would be is,
how many points on both these
images do I need to know?
For example,
would I need to know a point here that
would correspond to this point here.
I would need a point here that would
need to correspond to this point here.
I would need to know this point
corresponding to this, and
this point corresponding to this.
All right?
So, if I know these correspondences,
[SOUND] I would be able to
figure out the inverse,
by all this transformation function.
But how many do I need
to know is the question,
do I also need to know some inside?
Those are important questions,
so let's get to that.
And we would do this
in forms of quizzes.